[Music]
I'm just out here surviving then what
I'm doing right now won't even matter
baby baby it will always
[Music]
hey cash how much longer I got away from
my money God made this land for all of
us
greedy people like you want to hog it to
yourself and your family and me and my
family yeah
Cassius I'm your uncle I just really
need a job or you're to stick to the
script
Cassius green here sorry to but let me
give you two you want to make some money
here use your white voice my white horse
you ever talking about Will Smith wife
like this young man
hey mr. Kramer this is Langston from
regal view as always we'll be getting
that out to you right away you're doing
so good with the voice dang
all right
you're going upstairs power caller they
even have their own elevator
welcome power caller I hope you did not
masturbate today we need you sharp and
ready to go I got promoted my power
color today so they're not selling that
we certainly know there's no amount of
money that make me do that
here's the starting salary man I'm gonna
have to get me some new suits it is
morally emaciated I can't ride with you
I'm doing something I'm really good at -
I'm gonna make you a proposal I can see
that you don't want to say no but I
wouldn't do that before you see what I'm
offering
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah
you